>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
HERE TOO RESPOND TO JOE BIDEN'S
APPEASEMENT ABROAD, TEXAS
SENATOR TED CRUZ.
ENERGY IS VERY IMPORTANT IN
TEXAS.
SO WITH THE STROKE OF A PEN,
HIGH PAYING CAREER JOBS WIPED
OUT.
WITH THE STROKE OF A PEN, ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE IS WIPED OUT.
THIN HE GIVES A WAIVER TO RUSSIA
AND VLADIMIR PUTIN TO BUILD A
PIPELINE TO SUPPLY ENERGY AND
GET RICH TO OUR WESTERN EUROPEAN
ALLIES AND OTHERS.
SENATOR, MAYBE YOU CAN HELP SORT
THAT OUT.
I DIDN'T GRADUATE FROM HARVARD.
YOU DID.
>> WELL, SEAN, SADLY I CAN'T
SHED A LOT OF LIGHT ON IT.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY CRAZY WHAT JOE
BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS ARE
DOING.
ON DAY ONE IN OFFICE, JOE BIDEN
SHUT DOWN THE KEYSTONE PIPELINE.
DESTROYED 11,000 HIGH-PAYING
JOBS, INCLUDING 8,000 UNION
JOBS.
THEN BIDEN ALLOWED RUSSIAN
HACKERS TO HACK THE COLONIAL
PIPELINES PRODUCING GAS LINES UP
AND DOWN THE EASTERN SEABOARD.
HE SAT BY WHILE THEY PAID A
RANSOM TO HACKERS.
AND NOW TODAY HE SIGNED A WAIVER
GREENLIGHTING THE NORD STREAM 2
PIPELINE.
A PIPELINE FROM RUSSIA TO
GERMANY.
CONGRESS HAS PASSED BIPARTISAN
SANCTIONS TO STOP THIS PIPELINE.
WE STOPPED IT.
FOR A YEAR IT WAS SHUT DOWN.
A PIECE OF METAL AT THE BOTTOM
OF THE OCEAN.
PUTIN BEGAN REBUILDING IT RIGHT
AFTER BIDEN WAS ELECTED.
TODAY HE ISSUED A WAIVER.
BASICALLY WHAT JOE BIDEN HAS
DECIDED IS PIPELINES IN AMERICA
BAD.
JOBS IN AMERICA BAD.
PIPELINES IN RUSSIA, GOOD.
JOBS IN RUSSIA GOOD.
THIS IS EXACTLY BACKWARD.
IT'S ASININE.
FOUR MONTHS INTO IT, JOE BIDEN
IS CRAWLING IN BED WITH PUTIN
AND RUSSIA AND THE ENEMIES OF
AMERICA.
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
>> Sean: THEN YOU HAVE RUSSIA
NOW ALIGNED WITH CHINA PROVIDING
ARMS TO IRAN SO THAT THEY CAN
SHIP THEM TO YEMEN SO THE PROXY
WAR CAN CONTINUE IN THE MIDDLE
EAST THERE AS WELL.
LET'S GET TO THE ISSUE OF IRAN.
WE HAVE SOME PROBLEMS THERE,
TOO.
HE WANTS TO GET WITH THE MULLAHS
IN IRAN AGAIN.
WHAT IS IT WITH THIS IDEA THAT
JOE BIDEN IS GOING TO LECTURE
PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU FROM
DOING THE RIGHT THING, WHICH IS
DEFENDING HIS COUNTRY UNDER
ATTACK AND ASSAULT BY A GROUP
WHOSE CHARTER CALLS FOR THE
DESTRUCTION OF ISRAEL?
>> SEAN, YOU'RE RIGHT.
WHAT BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS ARE
PURSUING IS BACKWARDS.
OUR FRIENDS AND ALLIES, THE
PEOPLE WE SHOULD BE STANDING
ALONGSIDE WITH IS ALIENATING,
UNDERMINING, INSULTING AND
ATTACKING.
OUR ENEMIES, THE PEOPLE THAT
WANT TO KILL US, HE'S SENDING
MONEY TO, SUPPORTING AND
PRAISING AND KISSING THEIR REAR
ENDS.
SO WHETHER THAT IS RUSSIA AND
BIDEN SIGNING OFF ON THE PUTIN
PIPELINE, WHETHER THAT IS CHINA
AND BIDEN NOMINATING PRO CHINA
CABINET NOMINEES WHO ARE
UNWILLING TO STAND UP TO CHINESE
AGGRESSION OR WHETHER IT'S IRAN
AND BIDEN WANTING TO SEND
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO THE
AYATOLLA
AYATOLLAH KHAMENEI.
WE HAD PEACE FLOWERING
EVERYWHERE.
WE HAD THE ABRAHAM ACCORDS.
I WAS AT THE WHITE HOUSE FOR
THAT.
INCREDIBLE VICTORIES THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD WON BY
STANDING STRONGLY AND
UNEQUIVOCALLY WITH ISRAEL.
JOE BIDEN CAME IN AND IN JUST
FOUR MONTHS HE'S FRITTERED ALL
OF THAT AWAY, UNDERMINED ISRAEL
AND PRIME MINISTER NETANYAHU, HE
SENT OVER 100 MILLION TO THE
PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY, THE P.A.,
WHICH IS IN BED WITH HAMAS.
HAMAS, THE TERRORISTS THAT ARE
FIRING THE ROCKETS THAT YOU'RE
SHOWING RIGHT NOW, THEY FIRED
OVER 4,000 ROCKETS IN TO ISRAEL.
EVERY ONE OF THOSE ROCKETS MIGHT
AS WELL HAVE JOE BIDEN'S NAME
WRITTEN ON THE SIDE OF IT.
IT'S HIS WEAKNESS AND HIS BACK
OF BACKBONE TO STAND UP AND
STAND WITH ISRAEL THAT IS
CAUSING THIS WAR IN THE MIDDLE
EAST.
WHAT HE OUGHT TO DO, SEAN, HE
OUGHT TO STAND UP AND SAY RATHER
THAN LECTURING NETANYAHU AND
RATHER THAN BEING ARROGANT AND
ATTACKING OUR FRIENDS, HE OUGHT
TO SAY AMERICA STANDS WITH
ISRAEL, PERIOD, THE END.
THE HAMAS TERRORISTS NEED TO
STOP RIGHT NOW.
ISRAEL HAS AN ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO
DEFEND ITSELF.
IF HAMAS ATTACKS ISRAEL, THEY
WILL BE DEALT WITH AND THEY WILL
BE KILLED.
HE NEEDS TO RIGHT NOW REPLENISH
ISRAEL'S IRON DOME MISSILES.
THEY'RE FIRING MISSILES TO
INTERCEPT THESE ROCKETS.
THEY FIRED THOUSANDS OF
MISSILES.
INSTEAD, JOE BIDEN IS APPEASING
AOC AND TALIB AND THE RADICAL
LEFT.
>> Sean: IT'S CLEAR TO ME AND
IT'S INEXPLICABLE TO ME, NEITHER
BIDEN, PELOSI OR SCHUMER CONDEMN
THE SQUAD AND THE SEMITISM THAT
IS EXISTED SOME OF THE MEMBERS
THAT WE CHRONICLED IN DETAIL ON
THIS PROGRAM.
MY QUESTION NOW IS, OKAY, WITH
THE INSTABILITY CREATED IN THE
MIDDLE EAST, THE NEW UNHOLY
ALLIANCE RUSSIA, CHINA AND IRAN
FIGHTING THE PROXY WAR,
ELIMINATING ENERGY INDEPENDENCE
HERE AT HOME, THE PRICE OF OIL
IS ALREADY GOING UP, KNOCKING
OUT HIGH-PAYING CAREER ENERGY
JOBS FOR PEOPLE IN YOUR STATE OF
TEXAS AND ELSEWHERE.
OKAY.
WHAT IS THE NET RESULT?
WE HURT OUR NATIONAL SECURITY
AND PAY FOR FOR EVERYTHING WE
BUY IN EVERY STORE COUPLED WITH
INFLATION.
ALSO WE PAY MORE FOR GAS TO FILL
UP OUR TANKS, MORE FOR HEATING,
MORE FOR COOLING OUR HOMES.
WHO WINS HERE?
>> THE BAD GUYS AND ENEMY
IE
AMERICA.
JOE BIDEN HAS HANDED IT OVER TO
ELIZABETH WARREN AND BERNIE
SANDERS.
WE HAVE A BORDER CRISIS, OVER
TWO MILLION PROJECTED TO COME
HERE ILLEGALLY THIS YEAR.
A GAS CRISIS OF GAS LINES AND
SKY ROCKETING ENERGY PRICES.
WE'RE ON THE VERGE OF AN
INFLATION CRISIS AS THE NUMBERS
ARE RISING UP AND UP AND WAR IN
THE MIDDLE EAST.
WE'RE FOUR MONTHS IN.
IT'S TERRIFYING TO THINK WHAT
WILL HAPPEN IN THE NEXT FOUR
MONTHS.
ALL OF THESE ARE FAILURES OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS A REPRISE OF THE 1970s.
YOU AND I ARE BOTH OLD ENOUGH TO
REMEMBER THE 70s.
JOE BIDEN IS JIMMY CARTER 2.0.
KAMALA HARRIS IS WALTER MONDALE
AND THE DISASTERS THEY'RE
PRODUCING ARE FAILING AT HOME,
ECONOMICALLY, DOMESTICALLY AND
ABROAD.
WE GOT TO STOP IT.
WE NEED TO STAND WITH ISRAEL,
STAND WITH OUR FRIEND AND I'M
LEADING THE FIGHT TO DO THAT.
I'M HEADED TO ISRAEL SHORTLY TO
STAND WITH ISRAEL AND ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE WHAT THEY NEED TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES.
>> Sean: ONLY ONE